vor 16 millionen jahren soll der urzeit
heim megalodon ausgestorben sein
doch es gibt nicht wenige die fest davon
überzeugt sind dass eines der größten
meerestiere aller zeiten heutzutage
immer noch in der tiefsee lebt ihr habt
euch dieses video bei whatsapp gewünscht
und bekommt deswegen jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zum uhrzeit wie
realistisch ist es wirklich dass er auch
heute noch die gewässer unsicher macht
also jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
den link zur whatsapp gibt's wie immer
am ende des videos der uhrzeit ein mega
london gehört mit zu den größten reihen
die jemals auf der erde gelebt haben er
war wirklich riesig rekonstruktionen des
kiefers lassen auf eine körperlänge von
17 metern schließen dass es drei mal so
groß wie der weiße hai einige seiner
zähne waren wohl unglaubliche 17
zentimeter lang so groß also wie eine
menschliche etwas größere hand und diese
zähne machen es möglich dass sowohl
wasser als auch delfine auf seiner
speisekarte standen es war der räuber
schlechthin ganz oben in der
nahrungskette und hat wohl in warmen und
flachen gewässern seine beute gejagt
doch fest steht auch es gibt keinen
beweis dafür dass der urzeit tatsächlich
ausgestorben ist und nicht zu vergessen
die berichte von riesigen kraken sie
ungeheuern wurden auch jahrzehntelang
für seemannsgarn gehalten bis sie
entdeckt wurden erst seit einigen jahren
ist klar es gibt die riesenkraken und
immer mal wieder tauchen videos und
fotos im netz auf die ihn zeigen sollen
also jetzt den riesenhai wir werfen
jetzt mal einen blick auf die fakten die
einst zeugen berichten von riesigen
hallen immer mal wieder tauchen fotos
gigantischer haie auf große diskussion
gab es auch um ein bild das in dem film
megalodon der monster einlebt gezeigt
wurde einrücken und schwanzflosse neben
einem u-boot doch das war kein
dokumentarfilm sondern eine mockumentary
also keine echte dokumentation ein
hinweis darauf gab es lediglich im
abspann die wissenschaftler im film
waren schauspieler und der hai in
gewisser weise wohl auch denn wenn die
proportionen korrekt gewesen wären hätte
es sich um einen 20 meter langen
gehandelt also ein fünftel größer als
sehr gut ein
zudem gibt es auch immer wieder mal
zeichnungen von leuten die den uhrzeit
gesehen haben wollen doch klar ist
skizzen von augenzeugen sind keineswegs
wissenschaftlich und ein beleg für seine
existenz viel wahrscheinlicher ist es
dass bei der identifikation ein fehler
passiert ist auch riesenhaie oder viel
zu groß da gestellte weiße haie könnten
stattdessen gesichtet worden sein die
zwei andere fischarten leben auch noch
obwohl man sieht für ausgestorben geht
sprich die entdeckung des riesen maul
heiß und der quastenflosser dafür dass
auch der megalodon noch existiert auch
bei diesen beiden fischarten ging man
davon aus dass sie lange ausgestorben
sein
seit knapp 65 millionen jahren und ja
auch der riesenhai ist groß fünf meter
etwa und blieb lange von uns unentdeckt
ein beweis ist aber dass noch lange
nicht denn auch der riesen maul hat es
uns wirklich schwer gemacht sein hobby
ist es verstecken zu spielen und das in
großen tiefen drittens der urzeit drei
versteckt sich vor uns apropos
verstecken ist es nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass sich der urzeit vor
uns in extremen tiefen versteckt eher
unwahrscheinlich denn seine fossilien
zeigen dass er wie gesagt wohl eher in
warmen und flachen gewässern wie
beispielsweise küstengebieten gelebt hat
zudem gibt es heutzutage hinweise darauf
dass durch seine umsiedlung in kältere
gewässer wohl mit ein grund dafür sein
könnte dass er ausgestorben das konkret
gehen wissenschaftliche studien in
renommierten fachzeitschriften davon aus
dass der urzeitriesen heiligen starker
konkurrenz und beute mangel aus stadt
und ja es stimmt wir haben bisher
wirklich nur kleine teile unserer ozeane
gesehen und der kunde doch fest steht
auch dass die meisten lebewesen in den
ersten paar hundert metern leben dort wo
auch sonnenlicht hinkommt und das leben
in extremen diesen das ist schon sehr
speziell und große tiere sind dort bis
auf ausnahmen ganz weit unten eher
selten vielleicht hat er sich ja auch zu
einem kleineren hay entwickelt der auf
die tiefe spezialisiert ist ja und
viertens der urzeit hinterlässt spuren
bei einem australischen
forschungsprojekt wurde
staunen liches entdeckt eigentlich
wollten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler analysieren wie der
weiße hai beute macht doch dann
passierte die überraschung der weiße hai
wurde gefressen der sender von shark
alpha zeigte plötzlich eine rasante
geschwindigkeit an der weisheit tauchte
in eine tiefe von 580 metern der sender
verzeichnete zudem einen
temperaturanstieg von abt grad celsius
auf 26 grad celsius und das innerhalb
von sekunden und das ist tatsächlich
eine temperatur wie sie in dieser extrem
tiefen uhr im magen eines tieres
herrschen kann acht tage lang passierte
nichts der sender zeichnete konstant
diese temperatur auf und bewegte sich
irgendwo zwischen 100 metern und der
wasser andersrum der 100 metern und der
wasseroberfläche
dann wurde er wohl losgelassen und an
den strand gespült das forschungsteam
weiß bis heute nicht wer mag alpha so in
die tiefe gezogen hat war es ein
megalodon ausschließen können wir es
nicht doch es gibt auch andere
erklärungsansätze ein artgenosse der
aufgrund eines genetischen defekt so
groß geraten war beispielsweise und das
ist tatsächlich die einzige winzige spur
ansonsten gibt es keine anderen
entdeckung beispielsweise bissspuren und
narben von kämpfern walen und delfinen
geschweige denn eine aufnahme von
dementieren wenn ihr als erste erfahren
wollt wenn diese tatsächlich aufgespürt
wird dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp
an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video auch zu allen anderen
themen garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
in der redaktion von kriegs- und
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter dafür
draufklicken mehr monsterwellen auf
ozean gefahr auf dem meer ansonsten bis
dann bleib dran